nous finissons ce journal par une note
festive samedi la ville de maurepas
célébrer sa traditionnelle fête au
village l'association de toile et nous
battons a proposé de nombreuses
prestations aux habitants des jeux
étaient organisés pour les enfants la
journée et une animation musicale avec
soirée dansante clôturer l'événement
l'occasion pour les maurepas vient de se
rassembler et de profits mais profitez
de cette journée conviviale à l'écouter
on trouve des spectacles pour le moment
du des jeux pour les enfants un
restaurant qui est très attractif des
très bons donc que demander de plus on y
trouve un petit peu de joie et puis les
gens qui se rencontrent qui se retrouve
c'est une ambiance de village tout
simplement on se croirait dans un
village très loin de paris